und jetzt reden wir über Fett Comedy und
Oliver Pocher dieses unsäglich
Aufeinandertreffen der beiden diese
brutale Ohrfeige von diesem
selbsternannten Comedian fettcomedy
gegen Oliver Pocher am Rande des
Boxrings ja ein heftiger Schlag und
jetzt schlägt Oliver Pocher zurück aber
juristisch
Folge brutal hinterrücks es ist der 28
März 2022 fettcomedy alias Oma schlägt
Oliver Pocher in aller Öffentlichkeit am
Rande eines Boxkampfes von Felix Sturm
in der Dortmunder Westfalenhalle Pocher
wankt daraufhin umher ist nicht mehr
Herr der Lage wird daraufhin aus der
Halle begleitet er erstattet Anzeige
trägt laut eigenen Angaben irre parable
Schäden davon immer wieder kommt es
danach zum verbalen Schlagabtausch
zwischen Pocher und Fett Comedy auf
Social Media in Frankfurt beantragen
Pochers Anwälte nun eine einstweilige
Verfügung wegen zweier prügeläffchen
fettcomedy postet ein Video das einen
großen Affen dabei zeigt wie er einen
kleinen ohrfeigt zu viel für Pocher der
sieht sich verunglimpft mit dem
Vergleich schaltet seine Anwälte ein der
affengeile justiz-soft des Jahres Pocher
fordert
250.000 Euro Geldstrafe der Fight geht
in die nächste Runde auch ein T-Shirt
postet wird Comedy der den Vorfall
zwischen ihm und ein paar darstellen
soll witzelt darüber wann und ob ein
Gerichtstermin stattfinden wird noch
völlig unklar fakt ist fett Comedy wird
sich warm anziehen müssen um gegen
Pocher unbeschadet aus dem gerichtsring
steigen zu können auf ihn kann eine
saftige Geldstrafe zukommen im
schlimmsten Fall sogar eine mehrjährige
Freiheitsstrafe
[Musik]